ただいまご紹介にあずかりました地球の将大です
私はですね独立時計師という
あんまり聞き慣れない
職業しているんですけれども
8ですね個人で企業に属さずに個人で時計を作ってそれを販売して生計を立てていくと
いうようなそういう仕事ですね
で時計といってもいろんなのがあるんですけれども
電池を動力とせずですねゼンマイの力を動力とした
昔からある機械式時計という
そういうものを
作って
いいます
大きな特徴はですね私の時計作りの大きな特徴はて作業を非常に重視して作っていると
いうことが特徴です
そのですねなぜ作業でボケを作ろうと思ったのかという
その最初の相当気になったというかですね強烈に
私に働き掛けてきたのが
今から約150年前
位前にですね作られた万年時計という
時計があるんです
これはですね
もう花弁メーカーの創始者田中久重という人が作った時計なんですが
大きさ的にはこのくらいの
大きさで
江戸時代の当時の独特な時刻を表示する文字盤だったり
月齢
月の満ち欠けですね
そういうのを表示する文字盤だったりあとは昔のカレンダーですねそういうのを表示
する
思考が含まれて複雑な時計なんです
で
その時計の中にですね
体の制度を決定する部品っていうのがあるんですね
そう
時計の進み大倉を決定する部品というのがあるんです
でその部品っていうのは実は
久毛が作ったものではなくて
ヨーロッパの懐中時計の部品が入ってるんですね
で
寿紀自身のその時計はですねあのう作業で作られてるんですその歯車をヤスリで削って
人が一つ
それ作り方を慕ったんですが当然そのヨーロッパの懐中時計ンっていうのは
そういうハイを切るための機械があってより精密に小型に作られていたんですね
レッスンでその時点では時計とかの亀裂に関しては負けたわけ
姿勢をとってたわけなんですが
それでも久し下は諦めなかったんですね
ヨーロッパの機会が手元に無いから日本では作れないなっていうふうにならなかったん
です
その自分の置かれた環境だとか自分の持っている技術
それを振りに生かして自分はどこまでできるんだろうか
そういうチャレンジをした結果がそのような時計ができてそれが今まで
今も残ってるわけですねこれは上野の国立科学博物館に展示されています
それを見た時にですね
それなら自分も手作業で
どこまで出来るのかなというふうに気付けたんですね
当時の自分も時計を作りたいなっていう気持ちがあったんですけど
地上にあるような高
最新へのコンピューター制御の機械だとか
一つの高額な工作機械中は当然持ってなかったんでですね
ちょっと諦めかけた時にその久茂の時計を見て
自分もできるんじゃないかなっていうような気持ちをもらったんですね
でそこからは独学で時計を作っていくという形になるんですがやはり今
難しかったですね
ただそれを通じてその自分でものを考えてその解決していく
その面白さだったりだとか
少しずつものができる喜びだとかいろんなことを築けたんですね
でそれでまあ今も手作業で時計を作ってるんですけれども
作業を通じて気づけたことが平気
があるんですね
一つはものを作ることの大変さですね
自分でそのものを生み出す大変さということに気付けた
もう一つはて作業そのもの
可能性と勝つとか
そういうことに気付けたんですね
今は
ほとんどのものがお金を出せば買える時代ですね
もうお店にいろんなものが並んでるし
一つちょっと考えてみてください
1万円で買える商品があるものがあるとします
その商品を皆さんはあの
ご自分で1万円の予算で作れます
運動ぶりだと思いますまあその作り方がわからないだとか機会がないノウハウがない
いろいろありますけども
そのものを1枚の作るというのは非常に難しい
で
なぜそれが普通にお店で売られている
越冬
やはりそれは科学が発達して技術が発達していろんな機会ができてその恩恵を受けて
非常に
キリストを優れたものが安く買えるような時代になっ
それはある意味で豊かになったのか便利になったのかもしれないですけれども
一方でそれに伴う犠牲というものもあるという
いうことを
考えてみてほしいですね
例えば
より多く作るため資源がたくさん必要になるか
より効率を求めるために機械化を進めることで雇用が減ってしまったりだとか
あとは単純な作業マニュアル化することで効率を上げる
それによって働く人の意欲が失われてしまうか
たくさんありませんあとはその大量に消費された結果ゴミがいっぱいできちゃうか
コストを下げることに集力しすぎて職場の労働環境だとか
環境
環境戦争いうことの意識がちょっと弱くなっちゃうだとか様々なそういう
デメリットも同時にはらんでいるということですね
一方手作業でモノを作るということは非常に時間がかかるんです効率が非常に悪
ただそれでもですねー
その手作業で作るその
皇帝だとか勝てその考え方
そういうのをきちんと説明して理解していただくことで
そこに価値を感じて
購入してくれる方がいることも
また事実なんですね
a
そこが手作業のその可能性
じゃないのかなというふうに思います作業でやることが勝ちにつながる
そういうやり方もあるということなんですね
まさにこの機械式時計っていうのはそういう要素が非常に
強い
のです
今の時代だからこそ
そのようなですね価格品質
それだけではない勝ち
そういうものにも目を向けて身の回りのいろんなものと
もう一度そのものを見つめ直すぞ
いうことも必要なのではないかなと
思います
手作業の魅力というところで
皆さんもあの
100m 走だとか
マラソンだとか
そういうものを見て感動することってあると思うんですね
で
普通に考えれば今自転車もある
車もある弊社もあるし好機もある
そんな中で廃部走る能力必要ないっ
で普通思いますがそれでも
すごい前から
第1回オリンピックとかそういう時代からそういう人が走る
そういうスポーツ競技っていうのは魅力あるものと人々認識して今も残って走ってる
ですね
で
そこはなぜなんだろうというふうにちょっと考え
頃
やはりあの人間っていうのは1日に24時間しか与えられていません
人の一生っていうのもまた限られる
その一生の中で磨ける技術っていうのも
全家ですね
ただ日本の足はほとんどの人が持っ
そういう人類共通の
制約ですね
その中でどこまで自分を磨いて
自分の能力をどこまで伸ばして発揮できるのか
そういうところに
魅力だったり
感動するそういうエネルギーがあると思うんですね
手作業で作られたものをまた同じなんです
その一生の中でしか作れない
僕自身も
これから死ぬまでにあと願望の時計が作れるか分からないんですけれども
多分100個ぐらいですかね
ただ
それでもと経営時代は多くの人に行き渡らせることができなくてもですねそういう考え
方だったりそういう哲学だったり
そういうものっていうのはこういう場でたくさんの人小
伝えて共有することが
出てると思う
将来その時計は僕自身より長いでして
それが次の時計世代の時計師へのメッセージ
なってくれると思うんですね
機械でできないからペレやる
そういうわけじゃないんです
てできる能力を信じているから
で作るこ
そういうやり方でこれからも ok 作りを続けていきたいなと思いますありがとう
ございました